all right for people joining us we are
continuing our discussion of
multi-computation and language design
around multi-computation
and we've done quite a lot of discussion
and i think we are at the point where we
should be trying to figure out
um actual functions to implement
and um
go to the next step and i suspect nick
will be working on this
uh when he's finished doing a bunch of
things he's doing right now
um
and uh
we
we last time we talked about
uh
well
we talked about detailed control of
evaluation
[Music]
we talked about um being able to
[Music]
know
um
well this is this is in
the world of okay so so one issue is
detailed
uh
uh
telemetry
and control of evaluation
so we talked about this before things
like uh given that we know we're doing
you know
um
doing a replacement
into an expression
uh you know where does it happen
etc and we both want to know
where it's possible for it to happen and
we want to be able to specify where it
should happen is that a fair assessment
so so one function we need
like the um
uh
it's kind of like this multi replacement
although i'm not sure that's the right
name for it
but um
um
you know rather it's something which
essentially is saying possible
replacements
of an expert and a rule or something
like that i'm not sure if that's quite
right either which then gives a list of
you know
a um
a tagged list
of possible replacements that could
occur
that could be done based on that rule
obsession makes bigger
and then
there's uh there's more like apply
replacement or something bad name
that is
to an expert
and it's a
some kind of tagged rule
that says apply to the specific place or
a list of tagged rules that mean
potentially
i i don't know you know apply it in in
multiple places and so on so that would
be the way that i mean apply
replacements would be essentially the
thing that you would get inside find
equational proof would be some kind of
tag rule that tells you how to apply
these replacements to this expert does
that seem about right
um yeah right
okay so then
this is kind of at the microscopic level
um we've got all these questions about
um
you know
we got past questions about pattern
unification
we've also got questions about two-way
rules
which are a new thing for us
but which i think are relevant to all of
this
um
i mean two-way rules
okay what's the relationship
between i mean clearly if we have a
two-way rule
of the form you know f of x blank y
blank
two-way rule
uh you know g of x blank
x-blank y-blank or something
we understand what that means
but is there a one-way rule where we can
have patterns on both sides or is this a
feature of two-way rules that we end up
with patterns on both sides
well actually what we had considered for
two rules is having literals only
how would you interpret
why would you need to go both ways
well that's a typical thing you do in an
axiom system
that's i mean
that is the quintessential kind of axiom
system story
i mean if we have something that says um
you know this particular axiom is
symmetric so
it isn't really an issue but
you know something like this
yes but i mean
imagine that on on the right hand side
for example you have x
blank plus one or something like that
how
what's wrong with that
that says anytime you see
you know let's say u plus one you can
well okay so this is an interesting
point
it's an interesting point this is a
generated variable story
so x x plus one
going to match four
that will be a semantic match which is
not what we're doing
i mean we would have only only these
would only be structural matches right
but there is an issue of generated
variables as soon as we have something
like this
okay so one thing is the detailed
telemetry and control of evaluation the
second thing is
essentially um
more or less dynamically generated
graphs
i could say which means things like
uh
find replace path
and um
and i guess there's you know the merger
of these two things is what leads to all
of our causal graphs and all of the
other things that we've that we've
you know looked at i mean because
they're
now i don't know i mean
let's see
what we really want to talk about again
is you know
um multi-computational
well
i i guess even just computational
i know what we can call it execution
structures
okay by which i mean things like
multi-way graph
token event graph all these kinds of
things that represent the whole history
computational history execution history
structures
um okay now and the final thing here
which is sort of related to the
dynamically generated graphs business
well
treasure these last two
is um
evaluation orders
slash
maybe there's two different concepts
here
there's evaluation orders and then
there's
um observer observation frames
okay which might be two different things
well maybe they are maybe there
i know this is determining
when you're dynamically generating a
graph
what is the
you know what is the updating front
and is it you know we've had
named examples of these
eg
you know depth first
eg leftmost innermost
these kinds of things
and then we what we want which we do not
have
um
what is the appropriate
parametrized version
okay what other things have we talked
about that we're not capturing in the
summary
can we look at this for a minute
maybe we should just go through here and
just take a look
uh
okay yeah the the other issue is which
is related dynamically generated graphs
plus
infinite computations
right we where you're
okay and again we can now you know we
again we're going to talk here
about um use cases
of which we've discussed
uh
um now we can also call this
this thing we could call virtual
pathfinding
um
use cases include
sort of uh the quotes logic programming
and then
also
our sort of quote statistical mechanics
and okay and then we've got which this
one here
well logic programming okay we've also
got automated theorem proving which has
the feature
um
you know where where the proof is
visible
and we're making sense so some of these
others like the logic programming one
it's less important there's not it's not
clear that you need the proof to be
visible
you just want the answer
that makes sense
okay we
written down here some of these so one
of the things that's new since last time
is that
um
we do think
in terms of design
we do think that
this using design or something like it
uh is a way of so so where we say
something like map
using
uh
well are we carrying no we're saying
using
it's it's like using a comma function
yeah using position comma
uh
you know stack or something
f
and then this
is
feeding
so that means
what f is actually provided with
is that
a typical thing here we would be able to
say
hash position
uh you know plus hash stack here
is that right
i think it'd be slot one
plus slot two
oh i see and then they okay and there
was a we needed a name for the one
argument form
well it would just be the one argument
form of that probably i mean i'm not
sure using it
it's the right name there but but um
okay so this is a way of passing
information in
to um
to these functions right
um
okay but now how does that relate to
i mean is it the case that we could use
a similar metaphor
in
no i'm i'm thinking about rule okay so
this is
for
you know this is for function
application
right and then the other case is
uh you know
um
kind of
additional info
for rule
okay so so here's an example so if i say
i'm matching you know
f of x blank
um
comma you know list y blank z blank
okay but imagine that i could do
something like this
where on the right hand side i say
um something like uh i mean this isn't
the right syntax but i could say you
know x
plus
um
[Music]
uh you know environment
in fact we have an environment thing but
it's not doesn't mean the right thing
but you know environment of
um
you know index or something
okay and that what that would mean is
when this rule is applied
somehow
this i mean or you know
let's call it ambient
it's not a good name either but you get
what i'm saying so in other words we're
picking up additional information
about the rap using around a rule
like how you wrap using around a
function
possibly
but then the problem is i don't know
where the
where the things that you're using get
introduced
what i'm saying is that here
map
is deciding oh i know what position i
know what index we're at
i'm going to feed that into the f
see what i'm saying
from the outside function
it's keeping track of that information
and by the way
i do wonder
you know could
using
relate to monitor
because one of the things that's super
annoying right now is that you can't
monitor a map
you see what i'm saying well i mean it
doesn't react to all the progress
indicator stuff anyway
say that again
what about i mean all the progress
indicator stuff i thought we were going
to have progress reporting arrow true
for map
ah okay all right fine so then
then okay but then progress reporting
is in a sense
it's vaguely similar to using
isn't it because it's got to pick up
something
from the innards of the state
i mean
yeah but the thing is using i mean of
course the internals of mac knows what's
it knows what iteration it's on and
that's where it's gonna you know report
its progress using is just saying you
know it's just asking for
those internals of map to provide
different information to like mapping
function so
progress reporting needs like the big
map and know where you are in the big
map
right
what do you mean yeah go ahead
but whereas progress reporting just need
the local coordinates if you like
you know but but you if you
but map knows right how much it has left
to traverse doesn't it yes it does
so so it has the big map
you know whereas the function itself
doesn't have the big map it just gets
the local stuff no no i know but the
whole point of this using thing roger is
that we're able to feed in to the local
function this is a generalization of map
indexed okay right i got it i got it so
for example another good one would be
you know fraction complete
why not
that would be quite an interesting thing
to be able to feed in
yeah
and that's kind of what's needed for
progress monitoring progress reporting
yeah exactly
also
this made me think about
um
oh what are they called
iterators in data structures
yes which is a it's a way of traversing
basically
yeah but okay let's come back down
because i think this is a good
concept i mean this idea of using
ambient state
basically the big picture here is
um
you know ways to feed
ambient state
into local function slash rules
that's what this is about
which we haven't really had a way to do
i mean we've had the stack function
for millions of years which you could in
principle use so for example i could do
an example here
where i say map
[Music]
um
how could i even do this can i say stack
this is going to be weird because it's
going to have um well let's say
f of hash comma stack
onto
f of g
f of g of x of uh
comma h of y
and then what i want to say here is
comma uh
infinity okay
what exactly am i seeing here
i'm seeing some
unevaluated am i totally confused here
no i'm seeing
inside of stack
ah
does that help us
well
do it
do a tree map
of that function of that expression tree
of that
right you're saying expression tree of
this
no of your f of g of
what what do you want me to do just tell
me change map to tree map
wrap the second argument in expression
tree
and leave the infinity yep
uh horrifying
hello
my my computer is spinning is it going
to crash
what is this doing is it going to eat
its own tail
i'm not sure if i can like i've lost my
chance to
you're almost going to make me tell my
oft told story about just the front then
to kill the colonel
i don't know that i can it's just
spinning
go to activity monitor kill the kernel
suggestion
do i kill the kernel here you should
first you should press
oh oh yeah actually that's it you can
see the memory just went up by it's
going up by about a gigabyte every
second
okay
uh you should probably force quit
well ian that wasn't safe
well it's 18 gigabytes oh
splatteroo
oh well
okay
um
okay so much for that idea
was that a snake that was extruding sub
snakes at a high rate maybe stack of
blank
might have been
too much
because it was stacking some innards of
tree functions and things like that
okay
well that's a shame it lost my um
quite sensible example there okay any
case um
okay but the main idea here the main
meta idea
is this notion of ambient
of pulling in ambient material
um
what is next suggesting here the ambient
of index should be rule slot
of index an analogy with slot
not quite so you're saying
you know it's like the hash index thing
yeah
yeah but it doesn't the point about it
is it's not
it's not like function
is not like applying to an association
well i don't know i mean the main point
here is this is a new kind of degree of
freedom that we've not really thought
about before
of
i mean this is a good i think it's a
good general idea actually
this this notion of
you know pulling ambient stuff
into a local computation
and so i think we need to work through
that idea but then the next thing is the
problem is
you know the next question is
how do we
record
sort of computation histories
because what this is doing is this is
allowing us finer control
this here what all of this stuff
you know
isn't this like a soul story
yes it probably is
right so i mean okay so using
um
right it um lets one grab
ambient state
and use it
but the use is still local
it's just going to be whatever you know
wherever you've recursed to that's where
it's being used
okay so then
okay so
you could
throw elsewhere
using so
now it's so in other words in other
words so so but what so is doing
okay the problem with so are you look ah
yes yes this is interesting right the
problem is so is it doesn't know where
things came from
so is you just get
just you know
just get expressions thrown over the
transom
i don't even know how to spell transom
and i doubt i've written that word
before
maybe that's the way to do it i mean you
could argue that you could decide if you
want to bring that along
well i know but but my point is i think
it's a using story again
within so
that is you know one could use
using or some such
to bring along
provenance information
in the sown result exactly
that's what i meant right the problem
with this is that what so is doing is
it's a pure ticker tape it's just a list
of things but that's what you when you
say paths that's what the path is
it's a pure ticker tape no but it isn't
always for example
in um
uh
for example there can be a sub graph
let's say you're trying to find the the
you know how to get from this expression
to that expression in some multi-way
graph
there can be a sub graph there
it isn't just one path you might say
give me all paths that go from here to
here right but when you do map you do a
particular path
don't you well yes you do right now but
the whole point of what we're talking
about is being able to generalize that
i mean okay i agree that this is okay so
look one of the things what we don't
have
is a way to
reconstitute
structure
in the sewing result
except
so that's that term
uh but
compel
says again like trace
well yes which is a disaster okay
compare
causal graphs and all this kind of thing
which are a way to show i mean like for
example uh we can show um
nick's latest version i think we showed
this before
of um
oops
there we go
ah where do we have this
there's a previous one
yeah here we go
so
that's not very well formatted but
that's a proof
okay now that proof is actually but it
is useful that that is a graph if that
makes sense
right it's a dag with with common lemmas
and things like this
it's also interesting that it's a
bipartite graph
what you mean with these two different
kinds of objects here yes
well i'm not sure
yes that's right these are events
those are the update events these are
the states
just as a petronet is a bipartite graph
well it's for the same reasons
yes
i mean there are events and states
basically
um
and and what we have got
okay so here
you know
in general
we have
states
and we have events
but
but so far
we only have
structures that represent states
eg you know nest list
does a fine job at representing states
but it has nothing to say about the
events
okay let's take nest graph as an example
does nest golf can we think of nest
graph no i mean nest graph
okay so a nest graph
uh
right in nest graph
the states of the nodes and the events
of the edges
but that's not equivalent to this is it
this is there's more here
nick can you say
so i'm saying that this isn't equivalent
just having
no it would have to be a uh because you
can have this edge
because an event has can have multiple
outputs for example
and multiple inputs
i see i see so it is a genuine so there
really is it's a genuine bipartite graph
um
and but we think that that's a fairly
general way to think about this stuff
the bipartite graph as in you have
uh you know you have states and you have
i mean
yeah you have functions that are doing
things to inputs generating outputs
the the function itself is the event and
the inputs and so on are states
that are fair
but but again
you know so what are our evaluator
see this is where we've discussed this
before we've got these two forms of
recursion in our evaluator
one form of recursion okay so i'm just
going to
evaluation semantics
which by the way is is what makes us
you know uni computational single way
as opposed to multi-computational
we are
unique computational right now
and
the way it looks it's always
i don't know whether we can actually
just build one of these but but it's
always something which is of the form
you know state goes to event
okay
this is
you know okay so this is the the um
this is the reevaluation
sequence
that's case number one
case number two
is the um expression recursion sequence
expression recursion
okay and that involves
going into you know drilling through an
expression right we all know you know
function to arguments etc
am i making sense
right those are two different forms of
recursion do we agree
and
i mean
this
is capturing
this form of this is the multi-way
version of this form of recursion if i'm
sorry well this really
is the is the multi-way version of this
form of recursion is that correct
but this form of recursion is i think
something different
i i think it's specific to expressions
like i don't see what it would mean for
string rewriting
um
well
it's a traversal order that defines an
evaluation order because the things that
you're
evaluating are
expression trees
i know but for strings the analog will
be the order in which you scan for
substrings
which i
would would be different than for
expression trees indeed absolutely
so i mean you know
okay it could be an analog
in string rewriting
but
uh eg
you know the overlaps option
is an example of something which affects
the form of recursion
in strings
if i'm not mistaken
and and by the way this this recursion
expression recursion sequence
becomes even more complicated for graph
rewriting
so just to understand that
what this needs in all cases
is
you know this is where the traversal
order matters
actually i think even that isn't right
that's not right it needs a traversal
order
um but so does this because i think
right as soon as this goes multi-way
this needs a traversal order as well
although this isn't quite traversal this
is a
you know this
needs an event ordering which is a
little different than a traversal
ordering
am i making sense of that i think what
it is is that the traversal order will
cause you to have a different sequence
of events
yes but you can also independently have
a different sequence of events
because remember the event
okay in uni computation
there is only you're always getting just
this line state event state
event right
but if that is a multi-way graph
with many events that could happen in
parallel
then there's again the question
of
um
uh
you know
there's again the question of which
event
um
uh can you um
uh you know which order are you doing
the events in
am i making sense
because in this case there's no there's
no question about that because there's
just a single path of computation but in
the case where there's a multi-way graph
the ordering of events is not that you
know events can happen simultaneously
and so on
that make sense
um
the idea is like parameterizing how you
can
parallelize things in different ways yes
that is the story of general relativity
in our physics model et cetera et cetera
et cetera yes
that's that's the
that's the story of our experience of
space time and all kinds of good things
yes i mean it's also the story of
okay so here's a confusing thing here's
a confusing thing
the you know we all we talk about
breadth first search
for example but i think that is
much more in this
framework where we imagine in breadth
first okay okay here's a confusing which
maybe maybe two ideas have been
conflated which shouldn't be conflated
one is graph traversal in a graph where
you have it it's sitting right there in
front of you and you can traverse it and
the other is virtual graph traversal
now for some reason we're thinking of
those two things together and maybe they
shouldn't be together i'm not sure
in other words
in one case right you can say i've got a
graph which i could make and i could do
so in a depth first order
anyway i'm not sure whether those are
not sure how those relate
um
let's see some comments here
um
nick is commenting how would an inverse
version
of sown reap how about like maybe
there's a word missing here the inverse
version of so and reap for injecting
information inside
instead of extracting it would look
isn't that just like you set a variable
and then you use the variable
or like a with but nick is commenting
about code substitution for evaluation
by substitution will be like general
message passing okay let's see if we can
understand what what nick is talking
about there okay first thing is a little
tutorial for everybody about
co-substitution
um
which is related to two-way patterns
uh let's let's this is yet a different
thing okay so this is co-substitution
and what we might call co-evaluation
maybe
okay what is co-substitution
okay so let's say we have
a
co substitution is next name for this
um
the uh
so let's say we have
f of x blank
you know something like f of x blank a
and we have two way rule something like
f of
b comma y blank is that going to work
here
and the issue is well let's say let's
say
y blank comma z blank
okay so here
we can clearly f of y blank z blank
clearly matches this
right you can clearly specialize f of y
blank z blank to be this left-hand side
right using the binding
so substitution
isn't this precisely the unification
it is closely related to unification but
this is a slightly this isn't yeah this
is a okay so the substitution says y
specializes to x blank
uh you know z specializes to a
isn't the question how this rule applies
to some other expression
no see what here's what's going to
happen
let's say we're doing co-substitution
well what we want to do is to specialize
this
i think i've got a bad example here no
you can't imagine a
f-a-a-a comma a is the only solution
so which means that
both y and x need to be a
are the assignments or substitutions if
you want to call them that yes okay wait
wait a minute so so you're saying
right the only case is z blank that this
in order to specialize this so that it
matches this
what are you saying you're saying x oh i
didn't see i thought that z was an x
sorry
uh next we'll help us out here z needs
to be a
but then
if those there can be anything it's
gonna cost us to the same
depends what you're doing your
substitution or just matching
i'm just matching yeah well
maybe i want someone to substitute
so it's obviously first
second one for the first one
in your two-year rule
yes what i want to do instead of look
one thing i could do is to say match
this to this but the whole point is that
you can match the other way around
by specializing
the i mean it's we haven't got good
names maybe somebody has a good name for
this it's like the operator and the
operand
right so one thing you can do is you
specialize the operator so that it
matches the operand
but the other thing you can do is to
specialize the operand so the operator
can apply to it
do you have better names anybody got a
better idea for names for those things
i guess i'm confused because in a with a
one-way rule you aren't
matching the right-hand side to the
left-hand side
nick give us a better example this isn't
a good example
there's a good example that we've used
to hear let me find it
nico can you tell us a good example
well
for in our
block we have like
row x blank b
right i'm gonna find it i'm going to
find it
when in doubt just look at this
okay
uh
where is the case here
um
this should be
that's co-substitution
so this says
this stuff is so freaking confusing my
gosh this is confusing
okay this is substitution
okay so
f of x blank goes to g of x
given f of a you get g of a everybody
understands that
okay
now what you're doing here
is this is the rule
and you're
co-substituting oh yeah right this is
the way to think about it right you're
co-substituting with that rule
into f of x blank
so this is the operator and this is the
operand
and what you're doing is you're
specializing the operand
so that it can match the
operator so then
it basically is the pattern in the
operator or is the pattern in the
operand
yes
right so in this case
x blank
is bound to a and we should probably
show that in the sum
in this
example anyway x plane gets bound to a
and so the result is s
in this case
oh no i see this in this case f of x
blank
is f a and so the result is s
in this case
x blank
oh i'm so confused what is the
difference between
the left-hand sides of these are the
same here
i can explain that you just have
different positions in the first row we
have
this is highlighting
x specialized to a right in the second
case your x band goes specialized with f
of a
so it's only x band got replaced oh yeah
that's right
right right right right right so this is
saying
in the second case
the replacement f of a goes to s is
applied to x blank
which means there's still that ambient s
lying around so the result is f s
that make any sense to people so are
these both valid co-substitutions
yes
they're inevitably both valid okay
and there's another example
so we don't have a unique cos like
replacement that a co-substitution does
no we don't have a unique substitution
either in many cases i mean this
particular case we do but with now
double blanks and the business we don't
have a unique substitution either
so
is
okay so is nick making a claim that
there is a notion of co-evaluation
in other words there's one notion which
is
you are sowing
um
you know
from deep inside an expression
you send up a flare
about what just happened and it lands in
your sewing net so to speak
right that's the case we've we've talked
about
right so in other words
somewhere so the order in which it lands
in the sewing net
is defined by all these evaluation
orders
but there's no structure in the sewing
net it's just every flare
sent from deep inside the expression
every event from deep inside the
expression that happened that generated
as so
it's just thrown into the net
okay now
is nick describing something where there
is a way of
re
i'm very confused here oh it's an
opposite case when you have like
wanna get a position for example right
you you wanna inject your position in
somewhere deep in your
expression
right that's why
it's the opposite way it's like the
opposite of sound reaper
are you saying like replace at or
something
or replace part way quite like you're
using right prototype
using position using index using stack
you want to inject this position
somewhere into expression in order to
use
yes
well you're injecting it somewhere deep
inside the expression
you are using
that thing in this function
from the ambient state now what are you
saying so you're saying
there's an inverse of this somehow what
is that inverse i don't get it
you are throwing
you are sending a message which position
you are like
trying to replace that
into your expression so that the
expression inside the expression knows
where this position is happening where
this replacement is happening
but wait a second but that's this
version that's that's
that's given that you're locally
applying the function or locally doing
the replacement tell me what my ambient
state is
but you were saying a different thing
you were saying when you have thrown
that go
this is the same thing i think this is
when you
sending a message inside of expression
this is an opposite of soul
sound reaper is like when you from the
expression sending a message outside
this is you like you're throwing it
inside i see what you're saying i see
what you're saying so you're saying
that
but but still
okay so for example when you sew you
could certainly sew the information on
where am i
right you could you could
you could sew the position
that you're at into that outer net
that's caught by the whole you know reap
thing
yeah
um
i mean the thing that i'm i'm i'm not
getting
is that
you know so and reap
have an unstructured sequence of
messages that they receive
just a message sequence it's not
there is no
you know when someone reap get their
results
there is no sense of the structure i
mean okay so
you know
in this case you know this so reap
receive
a
ticker tape so to speak
of what happened
can receive
okay and in that ticker tape that could
contain
you know hash position etc etc etc
but
it
it itself is unstructured
so in other words it it let me give an
analogy
this is like saying i mean look it's
very simple it's like saying map so
on to
f of um
g of x of
h of y
and map map all
so on to that and reap it
okay what we're going to get
is
oh i see
i want the last of that
right that's an unstructured sequence
of expressions right it contains no
information about where you know this is
an unstructured list
right it does not contain information
um
it doesn't for example contain anything
that sort of has a superstructure so so
let me give an analogy
in this case here
we've got all kinds of
execution history information right is
there an analog okay
is there
a reap graph
in other words which which records
the causal relations
between so and things
that make sense
do we also want to trace graph
or is this the same i think there's that
that's yeah trace graph would be the or
or or trace graph you know that's the
same kind of thing
yes because the whole point is what i'm
saying is
so and we lose the information about
what the causal relationship between
the different things that they generated
was
i mean so when we put like print
statements
okay what's the difference between you
know the print statement spooling out
from a program
versus
the thing that records
the control flow
now recording the control flow is all
well and good when it's a uni
computational thing when it's
multi-computational it's a much more
complicated issue to record the control
flow
so we have echo evaluation is like a
super primitive
like one step version of that
yes we do i mean echo evaluation you
have nested echo evaluations they print
out
with like increasing levels of
indentation to kind of give you that
kind of
relationship
okay well let's see what that looks like
i agree i agree and i wonder whether we
could pick up but for example we can't
pick up the tree
of nested echo evaluations can we
see we could have here
this could be constructed as a tree
could it not
there is an echo evaluation tree
we just don't have it
put something in the wfr
like
look at an echo evaluate like it's
looking for echo evaluation symbols in
in the evaluation
it's weird
right but but this thing here right i
could import this notebook and i could
turn that into a tree could i not well
so
you wouldn't get the the tree structure
from this those are just giving you how
deeply nested are you
uh and but why isn't that maybe you can
tell maybe you can tell from how deeply
nested and
whether you have an opening or a closing
right but i think it is a yeah because
it is a tree because it's just it's
basically it is a traversal
it's a depth-first traversal of a tree
i claim
that i mean that but the the sequence of
echo evaluation outputs i claim
right so map all just sticks a bunch of
echo evaluations in and then the
standard evaluation right is a depth
first traversal
right because because of the original
because of map all basically
well it's just because of how
expressions evaluate
not because of matter yeah yeah okay
right you're right you're right you're
right is that first reversal because of
because that's how the evaluator works
right but you see that my point that i
keep on making is once we can represent
this as more of a graph
we can go multi-computational
this is a sequentialized thing
but if we could represent that in terms
of an execution graph of some kind
we're not stuck being sort of one path
of computation
um
okay let's see we've got all kinds of
comments here
um
let's see
okay so
richard is saying need to order the
successor states
to a candidate rewrites at any given
depth
look i mean this question about about
ordering what you do next i mean that's
again this evaluation order thing
and i'm i'm claiming that
okay the point of a multi-way graph is
it represents all possible orderings
and a multi-way graph has every
in it
every event you could apply
every state you could get every event
you could get is in there
the question of how you traverse it
and whether for example you even
generate the whole multi-way graph as a
whole separate question
okay
um
let's see uh
yes right so richard is pointing out
in the multi-computation case in so and
reap
right now we are simply
returning the path taken
they're also so so for example
what i did in a version of replace find
replace path that i wrote somehow has
been somehow i don't know lost in some
way but but
let's take the example
um
look here if i label all these things we
can see
um
okay so for example i could ask for
the find replace path
that goes from you know i don't know
what you know
six
to eight let's say
that's a bad example
six to um
to six i don't know i i don't know where
six to ten let's say okay
and the whole point is there is you know
here's there's one path here
but there are other paths that i could
take to get there
are making sense and then then in
find replace path one of the things you
can ask for
is
the
the two limiting cases one is
give me a path that's fine let's fight
find shortest path and the other is more
like find path
find path
can
ask for more paths and potentially can
ask for all paths but the whole point is
okay that the difference is okay so
look uh
you know find path
versus us
find path graph we could call it it's
not the right name because the path
graph is yet something different
oh i don't know find
find path
paths graph let's say okay what do i
mean by that so find path
again like so just gives you here's a
path here's another path here's another
path right whereas find paths graph
gives you the entangled sequence of
paths
right okay so the difference is it
should just be
like paths graph then
like find is
irrelevant yeah
um okay so then except we've already got
path graph so that's why it's confusing
okay but any case find path
uh
just gives
disembodied
lists of complete paths
paths
graph
gives the entangled collection
of paths as a graph
does that make sense
and we could do an example here to see
the difference i mean we're we're we are
i don't even know how to do this but but
people understand the difference between
these things right i mean in one case we
could say go from six to ten and there
are you know five paths we can enumerate
in that case we're getting the sub graph
that represents all the possible parts
makes sense to people
yeah
like roger you you're on board with this
oh yeah absolutely that's the efficient
way to enumerate you know if you need to
give lots of pass
right
but that's not a that's not a thing we
can extract right now we don't have a
function to extract that right now
um
in in both cases this is like you have a
definite starting point and a definite
ending point
that is correct
now i mean but again
i mean
no
the deficiency is is big so so if you
blow it up to a tree you often get
exponential blow up right absolutely i
mean it's the no lemmas version of
theorem proofing
whatever
still an exponential blow up yeah
exactly it's cut elimination and theorem
proving for example which is to say
don't use or no common sub-expressions
they're all the same idea
yeah
okay
so
uh
okay richard is commenting
that the data flowcase is interesting
where you keep
where values are bundled with their
derivation history
yes
yes but that's part of what what is
going on here that's like
yes that that's right that that's
that's a um you know
uh
okay
you know
bundle
an answer
with its derivation
that's otherwise known as you know
you know compare
uh result
bundled with proof
that's essentially what we're saying
it's like
it's like you've got a proof assistant
here's the result and here's the proof
you know you've got a proof function
that
i mean essentially that's useful
when you've got something like one of
these path things
that's not very useful when it's obvious
what okay this is useful
when there are many paths
i mean this is it's sort of useful in
the
in the sort of quotes np case
so to speak
when there are many parts
and you exhibit
one that proves the result
i think i mean in other words in other
words that's the case where
i mean
to what extent i mean we used to have
things like you know validated primes
and stuff like this but right now we
don't have
you know we say here's the result of
your computation
we don't give
other than with trace which is not
successful
we don't give the trace of how you got
there
and again
in
yeah okay
um
the proof but i i just want to point out
the proof doesn't necessarily need to be
need to be the trace of how you got
there it could be
just the minimal
like correct answer that you find like
the best path
yes
say what tactics you tried that didn't
work
fair enough no fair point right with it
which with its derivation or more to the
point
or rather
a derivation
right it doesn't have to be the
derivation that you used
um
okay
all right so let's let's loop back so
we've got a bunch of concepts here
you know the first general design
concept is the using concept
and we've got two different cases of
that we've got the case for function
evaluation really we've got the case
of the two standard things that we do
which are
um
you know apply functions
and you do rule substitutions
so in both cases this concept can apply
we have a bunch of i don't quite
understand the rules case here
because
like like you know one of the issues
here
okay
let me comment on an issue with this
issue
uh
where is the position
what what about nested maps
etc
whose position is it
or is that obvious
like the position in the original
tree versus
the position and the result
now i think that's obvious i think that
one is obvious for map that is it is
scoped by the fact
you know it's the scope of the using
right because because in this case
let's say it's index
the only index that can refer to is the
one of the map the using is directly
inside the map
in a rule it's less obvious what the
scope is because a rule is a disembodied
thing that can be used by many different
things
so maybe you have to use
using like maybe using wraps a rule and
then you can have this ambient thing
inside it
like you can have a slot inside a
function
[Music]
yeah that's possible
that's possible but then that still
doesn't do it because the rule
could be used by i mean
the rule can be used by slash dot
and
okay so so what you're saying is
okay let's take the example of replace
replace all
you're saying
that
this rule here
is scoped to mean
because this rule appears within replace
all
the scope of the indices is to that
expression
is that right
yeah
okay i have a question i i
tony has been silent-ish here but but
i have a question does this does any of
this resonate in any way with the whole
sparkle world
sparkle i don't know but uh about this i
was going to ask how about replace at
level one compared to cases which is
also at level one
about the scoping of the index
the ambient index
okay let's think about that okay so
you're saying
you've got the interesting case of cases
of um
uh
you know
whatever it is
that's actually a really interesting
example i mean because cases let's
imagine
uh well let's even do select
okay well hold on we've got two
different examples we've got select
where we could imagine doing something
which says um using
uh
and then we could say the payload the
expression
this would give us select indexed which
would be very nice
you know
if
hash index greater than two
you know prime q expression or something
that's really cool that that would work
right so that's the select case which i
believe just looks really good i mean
give or take certain details
um now we've got the cases case
and what are you saying there so the
cases case
i don't follow do we need a separate
index and match index
like the indexes we do yes we do
in the match indexes right we also need
in the result
or result index or
slash result index
index and result
okay
so
uh okay in this case
what would this look like
so this would be
cases of let's say i don't know you know
blank integer
with
let's say assuming that the index is
greater than two
and
well let's just say ambient
of quotes
should be slash simmy yeah it should be
slash sunny
ambient of index
um greater than two
okay now what was the point that tony
was making about replacement level one
versus cases
yeah
so what what do what do we do when we
replace the head cases with replace and
specified level one yeah is
is it the same or not and then at level
two or level three
how does the index structure change when
when we specify different levels oh i
have no idea i mean we we no we haven't
look these names index versus position
and so on haven't been thought through i
think they would need to be additional
different names for like if you have
multiple levels you could have the index
in
the traversal but you could also have
the index in just
like the siblings
okay look types of data to feed in
okay we've got
the expression
okay we've got whatever that is we've
got
the position
that's reasonably well defined
we've got um
the
about position
i i was thinking that it matters whether
you consider
the thing that you're matching against
versus the first argument of say replace
[Music]
when you
use replace at level one then those are
different
wait a second i'm not understanding this
i mean so there is a this is the
the position
at which the action position in the
original expression
at which the action will be taken
was what i was thinking
i mean that may not be the only possible
thing there
i mean
action numb action count
which you know which
i don't know how to say this but i mean
which um
action serial number or something
that's a terrible name but do you
understand that that's the the nth
thing that happened
i mean otherwise known as aka an event
id
something like that
but but tony
is is the point you're making something
about these
the data that will be fed through using
which i don't think we're ready to
discuss properly yet where is the point
you're making about the very possibility
of using using so to speak
well the greater the great
number of possibilities for instance
ambient could have two arguments where
the second argument is the x or the y
that it was bound to in case you have a
more complicated pattern on the left
hand side yeah
oh i see
right i mean basically what you're
saying is
there's lots of telemetry there's lots
of uh sort of information about what's
going on but it's hidden
right and this is an exposure
and the question is i mean this this is
the problem of trace
which is you know you expose everything
and then everything it's totally
confusing i mean okay i think a better
way to say it is one of the very
interesting things with the physics
project and all that is that we've got
packaging of representations of the
of the ongoing structure of computations
in a way that we do not have with trace
trace is just a big mess
so the point is that these various
graphs causal graphs
all these kinds of things are a way of
packaging
sort of ongoing computation
usefully
and that's that's what we have to look
for here now i think this local thing is
going to be plenty useful this is just
you know this is this is easy to
understand what's going on here and i
i'm kind of somewhat optimistic
that in the case of rules that there is
a well-defined scope for things like the
index can anybody see that as that is
that right or am i confusing something
here
christopher or somebody maybe you can
otherwise it's obvious if you refer to
an index in a rule
there is a unique place at which that
rule will be applied
i claim
there might be
multiple choices i mean like for example
there's the outermost
like
you know you could have a pattern
where
you know something like um f of triple
underscore x underscore triple
underscore right there are multiple
choices for where the x could go so you
can give the index of where the f like
the outermost part yeah so i agree i
agree the outermost index is givable
you know not necessarily
consider the orderless pattern sequence
which contains an x underscore y
underscore and a triple plank
i see what you're saying so now you're
making the point
that there is a difference but but look
look the one thing that is true
is in the original expression into which
that
pattern is matched so to speak
there is a definite subpart of the
expression which is being matched to
that big blob of orderless pattern
isn't there
no your cl your point is
your point is we do not have a
well-defined sub-tree that corresponds
to an orderless pattern sequence is that
your point yes
you're right
yeah okay
um
well
that's what we have missing for
i mean i think that's a case where
perhaps the way to think about it is
um
question mark is
index
missing
in this case
i mean maybe that's the way we deal with
it but some of these concepts
just don't have
a um you know just don't have a
meaningful way to to be handled
um
yeah richard is commenting that shortest
and longest
provide a way to define
some aspects of which patterns
of all the possible tree i mean this is
another thing this is okay so this is
another thing i don't understand
is
um
so is it correct that when the variable
get
binded it always
has a position no button word
so i don't really see a problem well it
can be bound to a sequence
so what so what the position where the
sequence starts
or ends
i mean it's a span okay so so you're
right when
when a variable when a pattern variable
is bound
the thing it's bound to
is either
is at a definite position
or perhaps a position span
yeah
okay but but i mean i think i think what
we're learning here
okay so clearly there's a bunch of stuff
to think about with the using concept
which i really i really like this
concept this is a really good concept
um
and i mean yes there are tons of things
you could feed in here sanders suggests
feeding in the head
i
agree yes yeah that's a useful thing
i mean there's just a lot of stuff one
could feed in here i mean we could have
a whole giant sub-language of things to
feed in
um
i also think
in
your in in your tree map stuff this
would be very useful because this you've
already got some concepts like this
don't you
yes so
i think
so in tree map you we have extended
level specs where you can say like level
spec arrow
data or arrows like level spec arrow
subtree
and this will give you the flexibility
to
control exactly what arguments you're
feeding to the function
the other place i want to use this is in
the visualization options
so you can say tree label function goes
to
use because
that's a good idea
right i mean and this
right i mean we've had a number of
places where
we immediately have to use named
arguments i mean i don't like mail
processing you immediately have to use
named arguments it's hopeless otherwise
um but this is this is essentially
dynamic
all right this so this is a very this is
a very useful thing so okay so we've got
this one definite idea which we need to
pursue
then
uh
this whole business so one one block of
stuff is the using business clearly
worthwhile
another block of stuff is homing in on
how pattern matching happens
and nick has a bunch of stuff on this
about sort of which i don't know what
the right packaging of it is possible
replacements i don't know what that what
the right thing is there
um
i think that's at some level a little
bit nerdier
than some of this other stuff in terms
of i think it's it's less you know we've
been able to survive an awfully large
number of years without having this
information
except internally but i kind of think
it's going to be useful
now
um
okay then we've got
the whole thing about representing
computation histories
and there's we've got
the beginnings of a way to do that we've
got lots of prototype stuff from the
physics project
and
one use case there
okay so we've got okay we got the
classes of problems
like logic programming type problems
where things are naturally parallel
where they're naturally multiple paths
we've also got the possibility of actual
implementation of that
in speculative evaluation in um
speculative execution
in and gpus and all this kind of fancy
stuff
i don't know how realistic i mean does
anybody have a sense of how
assume that we could define a virtual
pathfinding
function
okay does anybody know i mean in terms
of of practical multi-threaded
speculative execution
type architectures is there anything we
could actually hook into there
you know for example does llvm have the
capability
to hook into
those levels of
cpu operations
any ideas
the
um
yeah i mean richard's comment in auto
vectorization that that's definitely one
thing but that's
i'm i'm thinking of a
you know i mean it could very well be
that what we can define with our
multi-weight graphs
okay is it it's a i don't even know how
they i remember when people were doing
this back in the 90s people had you know
we're trying to figure out does this
fortran program
you know can this fortran program be
parallelized and they had essentially
execution graphs for that but i have no
idea what happened to all that stuff
and whether
you know in other words if i give you
a okay i have an ordinary piece of code
like procedural code and it says do this
do this do this do this
if i handed you a multi-way graph
and say
do this
in your cpu is there any way to take
that and do anything with it
is that does that question make sense i
mean
there
roger do you have any particular
comments on this
well
i mean most of them derive the graph
they need the compiler derives a graph
that the processor derives a graph
and uses it
um
but when the compiler derives a graph
it's never
i don't know whether you can communicate
you know in speculative evaluation
speculative execution
these are two paths you could go on in
parallel i'm not sure there's any way to
communicate that
i'm sure i think that may be just
automatically unpacked from the machine
code by the processor
yeah
some you can specify a method
which is basically tri-speculative
parallelism
and the first method to succeed will
return
i see which is which is following all
branches of an f things like that yeah
it will try
we'll try many methods in parallel
but by method you mean different
branches of an if for example
no i mean
the
the the sophisticated functions that we
have like solver functions
they're all poly algorithmic and there's
there's usually many
algorithms that can apply to any one
problem
right so this one says try all of them
that applies to this problem
okay so that's analogous to parallel try
yes
okay
but that's very i mean parallel tries
very coarse-grained parallelism
yes
i mean the the thing with these
multi-way graphs
is they potentially represent
extremely fine-grained
parallel computations
i bet that the situation is this i bet
this is the case
i mean
look a flow chart for example
has a particular form where there is a
path you take through it
you could imagine and i know people make
these
a sort of parallelized flow flow chart
i mean the whole point here the meta
point that we need to wrap up in a
second is what's the answer supposed to
be
right if the answer is always one thing
then in the end you just want a path
that gets to that one thing but that
relates to this kind of observer
question of what is it that you're
trying to actually measure
in other words
if you're trying to measure something
like what is the overall probability
distribution of outcomes
just going down one path isn't what you
want
right
and so
then
you know then it becomes more
interesting you know the flow chart
generalization
in which you have many paths yeah
but i feel that we need i mean
kind of both things we need something in
the language that allows for parallelism
like
like right now i always get the argument
our evaluator can't be parallelized
like fine write a new evaluator how hard
can it be
um
but when we need constructs in the
language that are concurrency constructs
that says
like treaties is independent and and
but my point roger is this my point is i
think multi-weight graphs i mean having
looked at all this process algebra stuff
and all these kinds of things and you
know on the petri net stuff and all this
stuff
the question is what is a reasonably
civilized i think multi-way graphs are
the civilized way
or these token event graphs are the
civilized way to represent parallelism
i think you can say
you know here is a token event graph
now the fact is that why are they
civilized part of the reason they're
civilized is because we have generators
for them
now you know okay look you can make a
hand-built token event graph where every
event is different for example okay
that's a lot of work
our token event graphs are something
which has not really been most of what's
been considered in parallel computation
that is
a i mean you know a cellular automaton
is an example of something where there
is one generate you know with one
function applied you know all over the
place it's it's a vectorized thing
but mostly
you know when people i mean the reason
our token event graphs can be made we
can make big ones
is because we generate them with a you
know essentially replicating the same
event over and over again
which is a little different than the
most common the most common case of
parallelism is either it's just
vectorized
or
it's um you know or it's sort of
hand-drawn parallelism where there are
many different events and you specify
what each of them is i think
um
anyway i mean i i
yeah you you
i basically what i'm saying is
i don't think the existing calculate for
specifying concurrency are you know i
just i think they're very messy
and i think we can do better
i think that's what that's sort of what
we've learned from the physics project
is that there is a cleaner way to
represent you know
but it's a little bit urgent stephen i'm
just you know for the longest time
i just feel that there's there's more
and more resources we are not using on
the standard generic consumer hardware
um laptops now comes standardly with 10
to 12 cpus
um
and probably
you know with dozens of gpus
right but look the best path probably
is okay first thing is
you know
this is not an insuperable design
problem
you know we're digging away at it here
i think that
you know
the concept of a parallel evaluator
makes a lot more sense in the context of
the compiler i think
i don't know can christopher comment on
this
i mean i i think that
i i i think that like they're i mean as
we already have there are certain
there's certain functions that can kind
of have special multi-threading stuff
but if you want like
generalized code to be parallelized
that that's a little more complicated i
mean i don't think there's a magic
compiler i know i know and i mean what
i'm saying is i think that writing
parallel code other than vectorized
stuff is pretty hard for humans
and
i think the goal is just to make it so
that
you know i think the goal would really
just be to to make it so that
you know functions like you know so
certain functions like map and so on are
are are
sort of easy and cheap enough to
parallelize
that you know they just by default are
and then
but that feels like where we were 20
years ago well but the the problem with
20 years ago and and you know still now
is that stuff like parallel map you
can't just map over something in
parallel like there's so much overhead
it's an expensive thing
right you have to launch all these
kernels and so on yeah but the compiler
did the previous generation compiler
auto you know parallelized map right
it was auto it was compiling
running it
for certain things and that could be
parallel right even though there aren't
side effects and so on because if there
were it would be able to compile them
right
yes
but i mean that that's sort of what i
mean is that it's that's the difficult
part is that i think in general
you know for for a general program you
can't parallelize it but there you know
in in most cases depending on how it's
written you can
um
and it's sort of a question of if you
can do it cheaply enough which may
involve
changes to the way the evaluator work
i think that would be you know yeah yeah
that's where we're at you know so so
i even kicked this off we kicked it off
a little bit and then we stopped of
using the current parallel tools because
they're they are at the process level
yeah with separate mathematica and
that's fine for certain you know big
things
um you have a few functions that use
them directly and they're more wfr
functions that have you know
parallelized true and full you know
whatever it is right it's a very
heavyweight thing i mean but we could
start massively doing that in symbolic
computation and we started but people
complained
okay we need to sort of this no because
the operating systems don't support it
properly i mean that's the difficulty
that it's all very good you know my my
machine might have you know 20 cores or
something but you know and then then oh
whoops i took over all 20 cores and now
my mouse doesn't respond exactly so we
need to manage that that's so like you
know we shouldn't do that we shouldn't
take it all over and we need there's
some center there's something i know but
that's well no i mean i i think i think
i i like look on on modern computers you
know in the last 10 years or something i
have not really had the issue of like
you know if i launch
more more kernels than i have cores or
or if i'm running some you know if i'm
running something in c and i i launch
you know tons and tons of threads that
are using maximum cpu and so on you know
at this point it's very rare to get a
your computer stops working usually the
problem is that your computer runs out
of memory that's when it like actually
stops working
but
i i i'm skeptical that that's really
that that on a modern operating system
that's that's that's that's a complaint
we got though christopher
yeah i'm sure but by the way part of
that i you know part of that might be
also running out of memory because that
is
because when you launch you know 20
processes you're multiplying your memory
use by 20 and and that often does even
today you know screw screw this but of
course if you're not you're right and
symbolic computation is much more memory
bound and sort of time-bound
but but there's lots of opportunities
there but we need to express this
there's i think there's no way in hell
that would be auto parallelized
so we need
we need kind of a way to
indicate where it can be done you know
what's really funny roger in smp
i had an attribute parallelizable for
any function i mean you know what's
funny that's what's happened to c o m p
is just that
yeah you know i mean they issued the
issue for us but a bit like like omp i
mean
this is i mean this is the thing about
auto you know auto or not auto
paralyzing things i think that the trick
is if you can just
cheaply parallel map something and maybe
it won't always be able to do it because
there'll be side effects or something
but but if if 90 of the time it can do
it then i think the point is is you just
you write your code using that you don't
even really have to think too much about
the fact that it's in parallel
sure
yeah i mean the concept for smp was
would an art would a function evaluate
its arguments in order or does it not
matter what order does it have to
evaluate an order or not yeah exactly
exactly so and that's what the parallel
map kind of assumes right
yes yeah but i mean right that's right
and it's i mean you know it's a very
simple concept it's like you can take
you can have an attribute we could have
an attribute of any function that just
says that like compound expression
better evaluated arguments in order
but you know
list for example doesn't need to
evaluate its arguments in order of
course you could have list arguments
that have side effects in their
evaluation and then it's toast if you
don't say you know i mean i wonder what
would happen but so now you have to go a
step further though i mean this this is
related that's this is exactly the
schtick of these like concurrency
concurrency things and co-routines and
so on but but then you have to go
further because then the issue is okay
suppose
you know how how do you have a deeper
structure where
each level of it can sort of be
asynchronous if you know it or it can be
distributed concurrently because if you
just have a list and you say oh the
arguments can be computed concurrently
you implicitly are basically you know
you submit all these co-routines for
each element of the list and then you
have a a wait a wait all
you know for those code teams and that
has to finish before then that list
finishes so i know this is exactly what
we are talking about here because this
is exactly this whole business about
multi-way graphs
and you know foliations of multi-way
graphs and about recursion inside
expressions these are exactly the same
issues because that thing you're just
describing about a coroutine within a
routine and so on and and you know but
maybe that's actually okay i mean
proteins inside of co routines i think
about if that if that would just that
might just work actually but no but your
issue is when is there a when is there a
synchronization primitive right and the
my my point is even the concept of a
synchronization primitive is a primitive
concept so to speak as in
that assumes that you are you are going
for one answer which you aren't
necessarily well it might not in our
current semantics you are but yeah
well i know i know with our current
function and for most programs that
people would
will write you are looking for one
answer
well okay yes i mean i i think that
there's a class of yes right but you
want to be able to parametrize the case
where you don't just look for one answer
and and it might also be of high
interest if we could do you know
essentially monte carlo
simulations you know i i agree that the
the current semantics
right i mean the thing is that the way
that most the way the concurrency is
generally dealt with in computer science
is you you sort of uh you sort of assume
or you try and prove that that the
different co routines are independent
that the order they run in they won't
affect each other and so on and some uh
you know that they can run in any order
so i mean sure you know you can say that
that can influence each other or not
just can influence each other or the
order of evaluation matters but it's
just that's usually the goal
in designing these things is to
avoid that right this is actually a
confluence property you want it not to
matter either not to matter what order
it's in or that there's some yeah
these things i think can be stated that
okay in any case but we have lots of
things i mean so
there are
particularly on the symbolic side
um we give you know we're happy to give
any answer that are equivalent to the to
the other answers yeah that's a good
point a simplification for example yes
we could do yeah but it actually happens
now because there's there's like timers
the timeouts
and depending on where you run it you
will get a different answer
but we should take advantage of doing it
in parallel instead
right since since the answer is
non-deterministic anyway why not
actually use non-deterministic
computation
yeah
right
we should wrap up here this is all very
interesting we are making good progress
here i see richard has has put lots of
references to lots of things in here
um
that's that's interesting and um
quick summary would be uh
formal formalization of the evaluator
would
give a lot of mileage i think
yes except i think it will be horrifying
i mean as in i think
my theorem my meta theorem about
evaluators is the only evaluator that
does nothing horrifying is an evaluator
that doesn't do anything
yeah i mean there's so much very
exciting constructs
right
even though you have an implementation
i'm sorry yeah the implementation is
quite long and complicated i mean but
but i mean the thing is there's so many
random constructs that kind of break you
know your formalism of the evaluator
like you know throw and catch and stuff
like that or so and reap
but that's the problem and hold doesn't
even hold means
uh all bets are off
no i'll tell you what hold this roger
which i finally understood
leftmost innermost evaluation is
non-hold
uh
what is it
oh i i think hold is no traversal order
yeah hold me and so you can do whatever
you want
disable traversal no no but but but but
it isn't because it's actually outermost
you see
non-hold is innermost you dig
the attribute is outermost yes
the symbol hold is the no traversal yeah
right yes that's right
the
anyway okay we are making good progress
um to be continued another time but i to
richard's point about about um i am
skeptical because i i think i think
you know i think what will happen is
there is a beautiful formalism of a
simplified evaluator that isn't i can
say the faster you guys can work because
we need that concurrency
i can say i have a whole team whole
team's just waiting for that to happen
tomorrow
you're giving me a hard time because i
say that to you about things that uh uh
you know
okay well yes well good it's good that
there's customers for this um yes
very eager
right but so what you want is
lightweight concurrency yes that um
of
i mean if you had lightweight
concurrency of compiled code
i mean yeah
well compiled code is one thing i mean
that's i i think the thing that's more
interesting but is
maybe a topic for a different meeting
would be
i mean similarly similar to the s p
thing of basically just having a i don't
know an attribute or or maybe just a
construct that that the evaluator treats
differently
where it'll evaluate its arguments in
sort of a concurrent you know it
launches sort of a co routine for each
of the arguments
nothing against compile code we are
using it and i expect us to use it a lot
more as it matures so all that stuff is
great but we want the other dip the sort
of the the regular language the question
of christmas
i mean
the question though that's going to come
up though is of course what happens when
you can't like what happens if they
interact or like if they share variables
and stuff like that
right well i mean i think what richard
is saying christopher is also saying is
if we could have even a lightweight
version of the evaluator that does for
example it doesn't allow assignment
variables for instance
that can have you know that's pure
functional
that
uh you know that can evaluate empower
you know where where we can kind of
formalize it and prove that it's okay
to do you know the evaluation in any
order i bet we can actually we could
implement that with actual co-routines
and things well i wasn't even thinking
about i wasn't even thinking about
having a minimal i mean that's
interesting but i would i would say even
i mean
like the thing i'm imagining and i need
to think about if it makes any sense or
how impossible it would be to implement
would be something where it's like you
know
uh
it's not necessarily deterministic what
you get back right like you don't even
have to like we might not even verify
because there are lots of cases for
example you're trying to
compute all these things and then take
the total you don't care what order they
come back in and and it might be very
hard to prove
that you know and the or it might be
very hard to control the order they come
back in but you don't care because
you're just going to take the total of
it in the end anyway so it's not very
helpful if the evaluator has been this
minimal evaluator has been designed in
such a way so that you know
uh it will
it will refuse to to to do it because it
can't prove that the order is is going
to be the order you expect but but i
mean the question is you know even if we
just take the full evaluator in some way
and
you know just basically run it in
i i'm just thinking about how collisions
you know how how because it's it's not
thread safe right the evaluator has
probably all sorts of things where there
are non-atomic operations that happen
and and stuff like that well it's only
non-atomic when it touches the symbol
table and so on
right so maybe maybe the i mean so maybe
the trick would be just to have some
sort of atomic interface to the symbol
table
and then
i mean i bet there are other things that
get modified in addition to the symbol
table probably
but i i don't really know i think so
where where are the clocks business
what's that
that's a complicated thing about the
evaluation caching i mean that's
complicated but i think that that that
that is only an optimization
okay
right but so maybe i mean then if we had
an atomic interface to the symbol table
maybe you could just have maybe you just
launch i don't know what you know
whether whether it's p threads or
whether it's you know the c plus plus co
routines or whoever is whoever's
co-routine implementation
and
i have no idea how impossible that would
be to make
that is interesting
that would be an interesting project and
see whether
um yeah i mean that would be valuable
that would be valuable
even if even if it involves switching
off all touching of the symbol table
yeah
although well the thing is the thing is
that
okay you say
okay
i mean read access it's clearly i mean i
think
what you're worried about is
modification but read access can't be a
problem i think you have to be able to
modify it in some ways but i think we
can probably make it look like look this
is a i mean again because you can't use
module if you can't modify the symbol
table right but but and no you can't use
any function that he calls modules so
you're kind of out of luck but but the
thing is i think like
i i you know
just having sort of atomic being able to
atomic modify the symbol table in an
atomic way cannot be i mean there aren't
that many obscure operations on a symbol
table it's like you insert you remove
you modify it's just like
this
exists and stuff like that right but how
thread safe is the generic internal code
of the kernel
does anybody have any idea
probably
but you know it might be the case that
with modern
you know c analysis tools we could
actually figure that
out don't honestly i don't really know i
mean
how how can thing i mean i thought
generally speaking things are not thread
safe because they're sharing resources
you know because there's some central
resource like the symbol table or like
other random you know global variables
or something that are set up and and you
know you're you're modifying those and
then so now if you have multiple threads
it's not clear how about how that works
but i mean your claim was that basically
the main thing is just the symbol table
yeah i'm not sure that's uh
i don't know i mean that's the question
i think there are other caches and stuff
that they're
set up
yeah things that they have
list and stuff like that we have lots of
caches but i suspect that we could
figure out
you know we probably could do an
analysis probably could do analysis from
the c code even using our nice
you know we have all that stuff now
which i don't think has been much use
that chris cooley wrote for um uh you
know making ast trees you know st's from
um
uh from actual c code files and all that
kind of thing i bet we could do an
analysis of whether
uh of you know what touches anything
that can be a global resource
anyway this is interesting stuff
and uh i have to go
um
and uh
uh
the um
okay there's also which is commenting in
this thread safety there's ordering
semantics
yes
yes
all right to be continued guys
all right thanks thanks to folks on the
live stream also